>> Tucker: THE FBI CONCEDED
TODAY IT COMPLETELY MISSED A
NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES TO STOP
THE PARK, FLORIDA SHOOTER,
NIKOLAS CRUZ.
THESE WEREN'T MINOR HINTS, THEY
WERE GLARING WARNINGS.
THE BUREAU WAS WARNED LAST MONTH
ABOUT CRUZ'S ERRATIC BEHAVIOR,
ABOUT OWNING A LOT OF GUNS AND
DESIRE TO KILL PEOPLE.
BUT THEY DID NOTHING, DIDN'T
FOLLOW UP.
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO THE
FAILURE TO CATCH CRUZ AFTER
RECEIVING A TIP IN SEPTEMBER.
S MANY HAVE POINTED OUT RESENDLY
THE FBI HAS BIGGER MATTERS ON
ITS HANDS THAN PROTECTING SCHOOL
CHILDREN FROM MURDERERS.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, IN A THE FBI -- THAT
THE FBI MAY NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH
COMPLAINTS LIKE THIS?
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE FBI ARE
STILL TRYING TO PROVE THAT TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA?
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE FBI SO
OCCUPIED TRACKING DOWN SOMETHING
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN, THEY MAY NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES.
TO PULL THIS KID OFF THE STREET.
>> Tucker: JIM CLEMENTE, FORMER
FBI SPECIAL AGENT, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE KNEW THAT CRUZ WAS A
POTENTIAL THREAT, I THINK LOCAL
POLICE WENT TO HIS HOUSE 39
TIMES.
IN RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS.
THE FBI RECEIVED A COUPLE OF
EXPLICIT TIPS ABOUT HIM AND
DIDN'T FOLLOW UP.
ALL OF US WANT TO THINK THE BEST
OF THE FBI.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENED HERE?
>> TUCKER, I STILL THINK THE
BEST OF THE FBI AS AN AGENCY AND
AS THE PREMIERE LAW EVEN
FORCEMENT AND INVESTIGATIVE BODY
IN THE WORLD.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE AREN'T
FATAL FLAWS WITHIN THE SYSTEM
AND PERSONNEL THAT ARE THERE.
HUMAN BEINGS MAKE MISTAKES.
I HOPE THIS WAS A MISTAKE I HOPE
THIS WAS A CLERICAL ERROR,
SOMEBODY WROTE DOWN A LEAD AND
THE LEAD DIDN'T GET INTO THE
SYSTEM AND NOT SENT DOWN TO THE
MIAMI DIVISION WHERE IT COULD
HAVE BEEN ACTED ON.
I HOPE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
WORST CASE IS THAT A HUMAN BEING
READ THIS INFORMATION, HEARD
THIS INFORMATION, GIVEN IT OVER
THE PHONE AND DECIDED THAT THEY
WERE THE FINAL ARBITER AND
DIDN'T NEED TO SEND INTEREST ANY
FURTHER.
I HOPE THAT DIRECTOR RAY BEING A
NEW DIRECTOR TO THE FBI IN THIS
VERY, VERY BAD PERIOD OF TURMOIL
FOR THE FBI, WILL ALLOW HIMSELF
TO DO A VERY PUBLIC EXAMINATION
OF THIS PROBLEM AND REVEAL IT TO
THE PUBLIC SO THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE FBI HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMINGLY POLITICIZED IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS, WE'VE SEEN
WITH McCABE AND OPERATE THEY ARE
CHARACTERS AT HEADQUARTERS
ACTING LIKE POLICY MEMBERS NOT
INVESTIGATIVE MEMBERS OF THE
FBI.
>> Tucker: THAT'S HOW IT LOOKS.
I GROW, AND I WANT TO THINK THE
BEST OF DIRECTOR WRAY AS WELL.
BUT THEN HE COMES OUT AND ISSUES
A STATEMENT IN WHICH HE LECTURES
US BY SAYING THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WORK HERE REALLY HAVE THE
SAFETY OF AMERICANS AS THEIR
FIRST PRIORITY.
IN OTHER WORDS WE HAVE THE BEST
INTENTIONS.
NOT THAT I REALLY CARE ABOUT
THEIR INTENTIONS, I CARE WHAT
THEY DO.
I DON'T EVEN BELIEVE THAT GIVEN
THE TEXT WE'VE READ.
WHY SAY SOMETHING OBVIOUSLY
FALSE?
>> I THINK HE'S PROBABLY REELING
FROM WHAT'S HAPPENED, NOT ONLY
TODAY AND WHAT HAPPENED EARLIER
THIS WEEK WITH THE HORRIFIC MASS
MURDER AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
FBI AND ITS REPUTATION BECAUSE
OF THESE PEOPLE.
THEY CLEARLY EXHIBITED THE LEAST
ATRACK TY TRAITS OF ANY HUMAN
BEING.
I WORKED UNDER REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS AND DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS AS AN FBI AGENT.
THERE WERE THINGS I FOUND OUT
ABOUT THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION
THAT I STILL TO THIS DAY WOULD
NOT REVEAL PUBLICLY BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE EMBARRASSING TO THE
OFFICE THAT I WAS WORKING UNDER.
AS AN FBI AGENT.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS SEE THAT
IT'S THEIR MISSION TO BE
POLITICALLY ACTIVE IN THEIR JOB.
THAT'S HORRIFIC.
I'M HOPING, AGAIN, THAT THIS WAS
THE PROBLEM AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PROBLEM.
WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU CALL THE
FBI, IT'S NOT A 911 SYSTEM, SOME
DUTY AGENT OR SUPPORT PERSON
ANSWERTS THE PHONE, TRY AND
ROUTE YOUR PHONE CALL TO THE
PEOPLE MOST APPROPRIATE TO
HANDLE IT.
THAT MIGHT BE A VERY JUNIOR
AGENT OR VERY SENIOR AGENT.
BUT IT MIGHT BE SOMEBODY THAT
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THE
INFORMATION.
IN THIS CASE IT WOULD SEEM IT
WOULD BE LIKELY IF THE
IS IN MIAMI THAT YOU WOULD TELL
THE MIAMI DIVISION.
SO A LEAD COULD BE GENERATED FOR
AGENTS TO FOLLOW UP.
OBVIOUSLY THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
AND LIVES WERE LOST BECAUSE OF
IT.
>> Tucker: THEY WERE BUSY